what is up guys we are back with another
top five combat moneymakers for mid
levels keep in mind that these are
monsters that I think are good for mid
levels when wanting to train combat and
make money but they may not be the only
ones if you have not seen the other
video I made on this go ahead and watch
that as well if you have any monsters in
mind that you think also make good money
at this level leave it in the comments
and also if you find this video helpful
leave a like the order of this video is
least difficult to most difficult in my
opinion alright let's get started I feel
it is important that you guys know my
levels before I tell you about the
monsters my combat level is 97 my stats
are 73 attack 79 strength 73 defense 88
wrench 70 prayer 79 magic and 83 hit
points now in order to do these monsters
you do not have to have these stats but
these stats are what I am basing my GP
per hour off of the first monster we are
going to talk about is lava dragons now
I'm sure you've heard of these but they
are still very consistent GP per hour
this is the year I'm using I would
recommend wearing D hide and then
bringing a trident over any other thing
and then any other stuff you're willing
to lose or keep by bringing a stamina
potion a prayer pot burning amulet and
then I'm also bringing food in case AP
care comes like I said only bring items
you are willing to lose I bring in the
occult necklace because it does give 10%
extra damage then go ahead and teleport
to the lava maze and then run to the
lava dragons
[Music]
once you are here go ahead and open gate
and then walk in and close it and then
go ahead and run over here I'm gonna go
ahead and protect from magic because I
do not want to get one bang by the lava
dragons
[Music]
normally if there's someone here they
will log out because they're just
collecting berries and don't want to get
peak aid stand right here and this is a
safe spot where you can attack both of
these lava dragons you want to go ahead
and hit both of them consistently the
reason you want to attack lava dragons
is because they always drop lava dragon
bones black dragon hide and lava scales
in addition to dropping those they also
drop rune darts rune javelins room
knifes rune eye bolts they drop an
assortment of other runes such as death
and blood runes they also drop onyx bolt
tips dragon javelin heads they drop
loads of alcohols they drop herbs they
also have a chance of dropping the
mysterious emblem and also the jus conic
visage now if you do lava dragons with
this method you will make an easy 500k
plus per hour but sometimes you will
make more dependent on your drops but I
would recommend you bring the pestle and
mortar so you can go ahead and crush the
lava scales and also bring a looting bag
the next monster is dust devils now they
do require 65 slayer to kill but we are
in current and we're gonna go to the
catacombs
and we are at this bank and see that
arrow that is where we're gonna go down
a rope now I suggest you bring your best
tank gear and you have to wear a slayer
helm or a face mask otherwise you will
die and then in my inventory I have a
spec web two potions and monkfish
additionally you can also bring
proselyte or initiate or monk robes or
saradomin robes if you want to use
prayer potions because you can't pray
from melee and stay here for longer also
if you want to you can bring bones to
peaches so your trips are longer as a
lot of the items they drop are stackable
but just run up here additionally
another method you can do is you
converse them in the corner I do have a
video on this if you want to see that go
ahead and check it out anyways you run
up here go ahead and drink your potions
switch to your spec web and start
killing them now the reason why you want
to kill dust devils is because they drop
very good drop and a lot of their drops
are notable they drop rune arrows
adamant ax rune dagger D Hyneman braces
they drop multiple battle staffs they
drop the dragon dagger dust runes earth
runes fire runes chaos runes soul rooms
they drop different kinds of herbs they
drop mithril bars adamant bars coins and
then they can also drop dust battle
staff dragon chain body or the dark
totem base middle or top and the ancient
shards now if you do dust devils with
the method I am using on screen you will
make 300k + per hour but if you burst
them in the corner you can make 200k an
hour if you use your prayer and use
prayer pods will probably make around
200k an hour the next Monster is correct
it does require 70 slayer this is the
gear I am wearing I would suggest
wearing a slayer helm if you are on task
but you have to use a leaf bladed weapon
I would suggest the axe as it works the
best this is what I'm bringing you also
need the dreaming staff so you do have
to start the fairytale to quest I'm
bringing a teleport to home to get out
of there a stamina potion and then lots
of food so I can stay for a long time
the teleport you use is to the relic a
slayer dungeon encode is AJR
[Music]
if you do not have the fairy rings you
can move your house to relic a' and
teleport there where it says province
and then run over here but go ahead and
enter the Slayer cave and run to the end
[Music]
all right once you were here go ahead
and drink your potions and start
attacking them the reason you want to
attack these for money is they drop
loads of different seeds including the
Snapdragon seed and the torso seed they
do drop alcohols so I would highly
recommend that you bring nature runes
and fire rooms they also drop loads of
herbs so if you have a herb sack go
ahead and bring that they drop stacks of
coins ranging from 44 cones to 10k they
also drop a lot of noted items such as
limpert roots flax big bones papaya
fruit white berries and coconut they
also have a chance of dropping a clue
scroll or a leaf bladed battle-ax leaf
bladed sword or the mystic rope top if
you kill kiosks with the method I am
using you will easily make 500 K + per
hour the next monster is the skeletal
wyvern you may have heard of this before
you do need 72 slayer to do this also
you do need the elemental shield or the
mind shield so you do have to do that
quest in order to do it otherwise you
will take too much damage
I recommend bringing broad bolts and
then your best range gear in addition to
that I am bringing three prayer pots for
ranging potions a stamina potion
monkfish and then the dream and staff to
get there decode is a IQ
[Music]
and then you will want to run to the
dungeon up here
and then enter the dungeon and then go
ahead and run north and then run east
till you get to the door
[Music]
all right now we are here go ahead and
enter the cave and as you can see there
are many safe spots in here there are
three safe spots you can see right there
two by the door and one by the pillar
and then down there where that other guy
is is another one but there are four
skeleton y friends that you want to kill
with range that you can save spot it's a
very AF capable method you can chill and
just relax and kill skeletal y friends
but in order to be able to save spot
them you do need to lose aggro so we
will wait here for about 10 minutes all
right now we are back it's been just
over 10 minutes and I just read the chat
and apparently the southeast spot is
open now so I will go ahead and run down
here right over here go ahead and drink
your ranging potion and then attack the
Y rent and since you have lost aggro you
will now be able to save spot them and
the other ones will not attack you the
reason you want to do skeletal y friends
is because you can stay here for a very
long time and afk for a very long time
the drops they have our wyvern bones
earth battle staff rune alkyl items so
that's why you should bring Alex they
drop a lot of different rooms adamant
bolt rune eye bolts rune arrows the burn
our seed and the Snapdragon seed they
drop a lot of different herbs so bring a
herb sack if you have it and then they
also can drop prayer potions coins the
rune eye crossbow unstrung and then they
also drop noted items such as magic logs
adamant bars unpowered orbs iron ore
uncut
rubies uncut diamonds and battle staffs
in addition to that they do have the
possibility of drop the dragon plate
skirt dragon plate legs granite legs
elite clue scroll and vitro conic
Vistage if you do wyverns with range and
you stay in alcohol the alcohol items
you can easily make 500 K to 700 K an
hour now the last method that I suggest
is a little complicated but the gear and
the inventory on screen is basically
what you will need I am NOT going to
show you guys how to get there but you
do need to do the Fremen ik trials quest
and you also need to move your house to
relic ah so you can get there
additionally I did make a complete guide
on how to do this if you are new so I
would suggest you watch that I am
talking about Dagon off Kings it was my
last video so I do recommend you watch
that if you've never done this before
but I will now skip to me killing them
and explain their drops the reason you
want to kill Dagon off Kings is because
they always drop Dagon off bones and if
you do have the free me elite diary
done you do get all their bones notif
which does add up to a lot of money also
each Dagon off has a chance of dropping
a ring they dropped the Fremen ik rings
Dagon off the Rex drops the berserker
ring Dagon off crime drops the seers
ring and Dagon off supreme drops the
archers ring you can make loads of money
here however this is kind of a boom or
bust method you can't spend an hour here
and only make 100k but sometimes you'll
make easily over 1 mil sometimes even 3
mil depending on which ring you get also
in my experience I do duo decays and I
would highly suggest finding someone to
do it with as it makes it much easier
and you have a much higher chance of
getting more good drops because you will
be killing them much faster I have
dueled with my friend and he got 4
Berserker rings in 87 kill count against
Rex so that is very good we easily made
over 1 mil an hour with the time we put
in alright that brings us to the end of
the video if you found this video
helpful please hit that like button
let's try to get to 100 likes also
subscribe to the channel if you are new
or haven't subscribed yet we just got
over 800 subs which is insane we're
slowly getting to 1,000 which is just
amazing I want to thank you guys so much
for all the support it has been awesome
if you want to join an awesome and chill
CC go ahead and join mine it is just my
username heart blitz and if you want to
join a super cool discord the link is in
the description thanks guys for watching
stay tuned for my next video